everyone Seawatch up with collider and I
am super happy to be with Peter and
Michael for the sound of silence here at
Sundance before we get started as I was
saying off-camera or before I just want
to give a huge thank you to Kia
Telluride for being a great sponsor the
only reason we get to be here is because
of Kia and I just want to say thank you
jumping into why I get to talk to you
guys thanks for having us
I really do appreciate you guys coming
in this movie I love movies and TV that
deal with professions that I've never
really heard about like and I can learn
about and this this film deals with a
profession I've never even I never knew
about and I wanted to know when did you
first discover a house tuning and when
did you first hear about it I mean for
me I don't know about the reality of
this profession I know that there are
people that are interested in these
ideas including a lot of academics but
to me it related more to something that
I see a lot of people that I've known
over the years get into which is a kind
of obsession with feeling better and
finding different ways of feeling better
whether it be through their environment
through clean air what they eat
different kind of types of exercise and
medicine and so I sort of saw it in the
continuum of what might exist in that
world but I don't think that there is a
real house tuner is there a real house
tuner Michael well not yet yeah I
actually like blood bought into what you
were selling because I'm like in New
York I would figure this is something
that would exist in New York City and
because it made complete sense to on the
extremes we both all understand this
that like your favorite song makes your
heart swell and then that irritating
noise makes you want to drive a spike
through your eye right sure but I think
that's that's what my friend actually
brought this idea to me
he had kind of invented this idea the
house tuner I've been you know described
this gentleman who goes into individuals
homes in New York City their apartments
and
you know calibrates their surroundings
their sonic surroundings on a musical
scale and you know as we started kind of
talking about that we developed it into
this short film but you know I think
what was important to me was I never
wanted it to be even though it's an
invented profession I never wanted to be
so far from reality you know it's
technically science fiction right but
it's um you know I I wanted it to exist
in a very real New York City and it's
you know in the movie we have him
profiled in the talk of the town section
of The New Yorker which you know is the
type of place that would profile an
individual like this with kind of a nice
I thought that that was real for a while
and that's good until I watched it and
I'm like oh this has to be real like I
totally bought into it it probably is
somewhere I just haven't found them yeah
we did find there is a gentleman in the
city who is kind of a professional sound
proofer and you know he you read about
him in the New York Times kind of real
estate section every other weekend about
some sort of kind of neighbor noise
dispute and we modeled the tools that
you know Peters character carries in his
tool bag off of you know what someone in
a sound engineering field would actually
carry so we tried to make it as
authentic as possible even though it's
we were really into the tool bag that
was the first thing that I wanted to
sort out I actually know someone um who
forgot to very wealthy people he's based
in Chelsea comes in and makes it so your
air conditioning doesn't make any noise
and encourages you to cook on an
induction top so there's no off gassing
and that's sort of you know extreme
control of your environment that a lot
of people get into these days is I think
something that's it's very interesting
and also the nature of obsession of you
know whether your obsession be living in
a pure environment or living in an
environment where the sound is exactly
as it should be to make you feel
comforted and have less anxiety this
sound is pretty good in here well take a
look they soundproof over the last year
which is why this might be the best room
that I've been in and Sundance so far
perhaps yeah yeah I was saying earlier
because we did interviews here at the
Mustang restaurant in in Park City and
last year we did interviews and it's
infinitely better this year with the
sound quality yeah
something that there's two things I
really want to talk about hi I loved the
opening shot which is the old New York
City and I'm doing this sound test where
did that shot come from and what was the
inspiration for putting it in the film
yeah so it's it's from the archives of
the the Fox Movietone reels which were a
35-millimeter night raid and it's a
treasure trove of you know kind of
bizarre but interesting documentary
footage from that you know that era of
New York that specific shot is from 1929
that we found them in our and our
research that we did when we were
writing but it's the the Department of
Health in New York City you know there
was so much kind of this is around the
time of you know just after the
Industrial Revolution there's a lot more
noise in a city like New York so people
who were complaining enough to that yeah
they weren't used to it yet yeah the
Industrial Revolution happened in
everyone what and so they they they they
hired this group of individuals known as
the noise abatement Commission to go
around New York and record the decibel
level and the decibel had actually just
been introduced at that point so it was
this new kind of you know measurement
system and you know I you know visually
loved that they're using you know very
old kind of vintage microphones and
recording equipment and all dressed kind
of to the nines and top coats when
people used to dress well in New York
City
but you know they they determined at the
time that Times Square and an area
formerly known as radio Row where the
World Trade Center was where they sold
upright radios were the noisiest in the
city and they produced a really well
designed pamphlet called city noise and
you know it had a lot of data in it to
how to stop this but essentially you
know almost a hundred years later
nothing has changed we haven't fixed
we're all just getting used to it I
think you know you only notice that
you're living in a noisy environment
when you go to a quiet one completely
yeah was it seen with the stars when
living in LA you you don't see stars and
then you go to somewhere else and you're
like oh yeah we're we're in the solar
system you know light pollution is
something that could be just ended
overnight right literally I mean you
just how about tonight everybody turns
out the lights a little bit and then we
could see the Milky Way
like that right um I definitely want to
know about you guys how you first met
and that initial meeting and for you are
you like extra nervous the night before
when you're thinking about you know I
really want Peter to be in this or you
know what I mean like what is that like
yeah well I did really want Peter to be
in this and I was fortunate enough to
find a way to kind of get him the script
and I wrote him a love letter of sorts
and he responded to it right away and
that with that that that meant a lot to
me and we got together for lunch I think
yeah it's intimidating going and I was a
bit very big fan but I think one thing I
liked about Peter right away is you
within moments and I think this speaks a
lot to just who he is as a human and his
character he just kind of has a positive
energy right away and like just makes
everything kind of okay and that like
that trends you know transitioned and to
set every day but we talked about music
right away you you play a fair amount of
musical instruments yeah and you're
interested in sound and I've always been
interested in sound I've all but my
approach to music really started like on
the music theory side and then I play
several instruments but and I teach
music to my kids for example but I I'm
always really interested even in the
most basic ideas of music theory you
know Western music theory especially oh
yeah and Peter I found out has absolute
pitch as well which didn't hurt for this
role
I wouldn't test it right now but what
one at one of the daughter and my
daughter actually I think you know might
well say and so just I think about time
a lot but the when when Peter and I met
and first talked about the project it
was about a year before we actually
physically made the movie and I you know
once he was interested I just you know I
felt like it was my job just keep keep
that momentum going and he came over to
my apartment early on in the process and
we recorded the script just like this on
microphones just so I could start
hearing it and it was incredibly helpful
for me because suddenly you know we're
this is where you weren't acting or
anything it was just just good now
cold-read but I was barely even reading
it for the first time you know you work
on a script for so long and in this case
years I could just press a space bar and
start you know listening
to the movie and I had this kind of
radio radio play version of the movie
for a while and that kind of
transitioned into an animatic but was
really a good like a blueprint for what
we eventually did a year later I mean
for me you know I look for enthusiasm I
look for excitement I look for ideas
that I haven't thought about in terms of
them being films which this is one
characters that interest me I really was
fascinated with somebody that was so
dedicated to making other people feel
better you know like literally going
into their homes and adjusting their
toasters and refrigerators in the hope
that it would cure their anxiety to me
there was something very appealing about
that and at the same time didn't know
how to make himself feel better and
actually had virtually only a distant
idea that he was actually even feeling
bad you know somebody whose energy was
so directed outside of himself you know
listening to spaces looking at people to
me that's always going to be a more
interesting character than somebody
who's a naval gazer one of the things I
also want to touch on is the sound mix
the sound design there's a key role in
this film yeah can you talk about the
sound design and and I believe you said
you got a you worked with Dolby we did
yeah we were really fortunate
Dolby had read the script before we even
made it and just wanted to be involved
they were kindred spirits I think they
saw and kind of what they did to what we
were doing and you know this role this
this the sound person so they you know
we made the movie and then it's it's a
difficult thing you know there's always
the the caveat when you're kind of a
rough cut to phases that you're you know
the sound doesn't mix you and that sort
of thing but for this movie it was it
was this tricky little thing because I
felt like it wasn't just the mix that we
were missing a character in the movie
and that really didn't you know come to
life until we were in the mix and had a
chance to design that close to when we
were finished the movie she just kind of
had to really suspend imagination for a
little bit there but Dolby provided us
with a grant that we could mix in dolby
atmos which is a wild technology that I
wasn't aware of at the time but just
only knew associated with big
blockbuster films and this
of expensive thing and for our movie I
didn't quite know how we would be able
to use it or what it did but once we got
into it and spent time and I worked with
the mixers and designers it was a I
really got into it and like we could
tell the story in this you know
three-dimensional environment and we're
gonna premiere today in Dolby Atmos
fortunately - which I'm incredibly
excited about because we can hear the
film I think you know in this theater
for the first time properly also it's a
newer theater here the sound and picture
in there is really good yeah yeah I had
a rap with you so you can actually go to
your world premiere
I just want to sincerely say thank you
so much for coming in I hope it's a huge
hit at the festival and again thank you
thanks a lot thank you very much
you